oh you turn it on
thank you yeah thank you Ron and
everybody for attending here on this
beautiful California day it actually is
beautiful we really needed this ring
thank you for bringing to us as Ron said
this is the boot camp is intended to be
to bring everybody up to speed and what
I'm going to talk about today is of
course probably the greatest common
devisor no denominator of that really
was just that it wasn't intended to be a
greatest common denominator of everybody
here perhaps so that what that means is
probably most people have seen what I'm
going to talk about but so but still I'm
going to go through the basics and but
aimed at a sophisticated audience so the
assumption is that you guys have lots of
backgrounds in algorithms and such but
maybe you haven't seen this particular
material and so if I can figure this
thing out so I'm going to talk about two
topics in this first our exact matching
and then sequence alignment and then the
second our we'll move to suffix trees
and suffix arrays and in the third hour
to burrows-wheeler transform and perhaps
some of its uses and I think later in
the in the week will be more discussions
about that you know okay so exact
matching is just that we're given a
pattern and we're given a longer string
T and you want to find all the
occurrences if any pattern P and texty
so if this is P is ABA and here's the
text then of course P occurs here at
position 3 and it also can occur as a
position whatever that is and then it
occurs over here so 3 7 & 9 and the
occurrences may overlap now naively you
could certainly do this in time that's
proportional to the length
the pattern times the length of the text
you just put them in the pattern
everywhere every position in the text
and then with two fingers one on the
pattern one of the text you
you see if their characters are equal
and you either come to a point where
there is a mismatch and then you move on
you move the pattern by one position or
you see that the pattern actually occurs
in the text at that position and that's
why this is Theta of the length of the
pattern times the length of the text but
in I don't know when it was initially in
early 70s
Knuth Morris and Pratt but I'm I could
talk about their method figured out how
to turn this symbol by 90 degrees that's
all we have to do this is just you know
you turn this from here to there and you
get an algorithm that is x this time is
the length of the pattern plus the
length of the text okay so a little bit
of notation for any string s s from IJ
is the contiguous substring that starts
at I and ends at J for example in
California LIFO is here life oh that's a
substring Cal as a prefix and Ora is a
suffix and then a single character in s
at the ayahs ition or i thereafter is s
of i and when two characters match we
say they match otherwise we say they
mismatch that's the easiest of
definition of all okay now the way I
like to do exact matching is something
that I called fundamental pre-processing
and otherwise it's called the Z
algorithm and the idea is that you're
given a string s and for any position I
Z is is the length of the longest prefix
that starts a position I and matches an
actual prefix of s so if we have this an
example s is equal to this string at
position 5 1 2 3 4 5 we have a
B which matches an actual prefix of s so
z5 of s is equal to 3 and this is this
is y and z 6 just to give you another
example one two three four five six
that's an A we have a B but this is an a
a so Z 6 of S is 1 z 7z 8 or both 0 so
any questions about the terminology or
anything else please let me know okay so
our basic algorithm is going to be to
compute all those Z values and we're
going to do it in linear time and
that'll be very useful for lots of
different applications and the the main
conceptual thing is what I call a z box
so we're gonna draw us Z box at every
position J where Z J is bigger than 0 so
at position J there is actually some
nonzero prefix or substring that begins
at position J that matches an actual
prefix of s and at every one of those
points we're going to have a Z box and
it will represent a maximal length
substring of s that matches a prefix of
s so it's of length Z J remembering ZJ
is a is a number and for every I RI is
the rightmost endpoint of any Z box that
begins at or before position I so here
we are in this picture I've just drawn
some Z boxes and here's position I and
the the Z box
sorry RI is the rightmost end point of
any Z box that begins at or before
position I so in this picture RI is here
because this is the rightmost point of
any z box that begins before or at I and
then Li is the left end of that
particular Z box so we have the c-bucs
RI and Li sorry points RI and Li of this
z box
so here this is a little example but
okay now the point of Z box again is
that this is a substring that begins at
this point and matches a true prefix of
the of the sequence so if this is
substring alpha here there's an alpha
there as a as a prefix of the of the
string okay everybody with me on that
okay that's nine-tenths of the of the
lecture and of the method so you just
have to really be clear on what does e
box is now I'm going to compute I want
to compute all the Zi and their
associated RI and Li for I from 2 to s
okay so and our I'll just use is the
most recently computed RJ value or are
either okay
well 2 to find Z 2 here's our string s
and position 1 position 2 at Z 2 again
is defined as the longest length of the
longest substring that starts at
position 2 which is actually equal to a
prefix which starts at position 1 so
this is what I call the two-finger
approach you just to two fingers here
one is over the substring that begins a
position to one is over session 1 if
those characters match you move on to
the next and move on to the next and so
on until they mismatch and I can
generalize this to the two thumbs
approach so that if I have a position I
and I want to know what the Zi is of
course I can just put my two thumbs
there anyway and move over like that ok
so that's the sort of the naive basic
approach so for Z 2 we just do that
explicitly no kids we don't know
anything else
okay so wait a minute what happened I
guess I went backwards I must have hit
the thing okay
so Z - we just explicitly by the
two-fingered approach and if Z 2 is
actually bigger than 0 so we found some
actual matches a a for example then
we're gonna set R 2 R 2 and R 2 is set
to Z 2 plus 1 and that's the end of the
this so this is the Z box here so we
have the ends of this the right and the
left ends of that particular z box now
assume inductively that we all we know
now Zi
4i up to K minus 1 and we also know it's
RI okay so we want to do is compute Z K
the next Z value and and it's to right
and left end points and update R and L
if needed
okay so here here really is the heart of
it all so we're given all of the zi and
the z boxes that are associated with
them up to k and k minus 1 and now we
want to compute Z K all right so we
really have three cases or so here is K
and the first case actually is that this
represents the case - the first case is
that K is not in any Z box
it's to the right of the rightmost z box
so we have a Z but we have Z boxes and
then here is K and this was our the
rightmost point of any z box so how do
we find ZK again just the two-fingered
approach just you can't do anything
other than direct search ok but the
whole the whole point of this is that if
you happen to be if K happens to be in a
z box like this ok
remember but the z box means it means
the
there's a substring here which is equal
to a prefix okay and K is in a Z box so
it's in this Z box alpha right so from K
forward is a substring written called
beta which is also there and again alpha
is there all right
so the point is that there's a
relationship between ZK which which
we're trying to compute and Z K prime K
Prime is at the beginning of this beta
in this copy of alpha and the prefix
okay because this whole alpha is equal
to that whole alpha and so from K
forward and alpha must equal K Prime
forward in this alpha
they're both labeled beta and that's
really the the key to speeding things up
so in this case to when K is in a Z box
we're going to have two different cases
2a and 2b okay so you look so the
algorithm is I want to compute Z K I
want to compute Z K I recognize that
it's in a Z box I have Ln R which tells
the length of the Z box so I can go over
and find K prime which is at the same
offset point as K is in that in that Z
box in that alpha and then I can look up
ZK prime okay because we've already
computed it we're computing these left
to right now if Z K prime is less than
beta so it says from here from K Prime
you go forward and you find that the
longest substring that starts with K
prime that is equal to prefix doesn't
extend to the end of this of this copy
of alpha so the same thing must be true
over here all right so that the longest
substring that starts at K and matches
of prefix is just equal to the two gamma
here the longest substring that starts
at K prime that matches the prefix and
so we're done in computing ZK is
equal to xik a prime and we didn't push
the boundaries of our or and therefore
we don't have to change L either
so that was simple no character
comparisons at all all right
that's case two a gob is if Z K prime is
actually greater than or equal to beta
so you start at Z K prime or a K prime
and ZK prime takes you beyond this alpha
well you know of course that this beta
and beta are the same okay but now we
can reason what's the next character
here and the next character here I claim
that they actually mismatch okay sorry
if this is Z K prime is strictly bigger
than beta okay so is the the match
starting at K prime actually extends
beyond this alpha okay well this
character we're saying matches this is a
this is a substring that starts at K
Prime that matches a prefix of of s so
this character just to the right of
alpha must match this character just to
the right of this beta okay on the other
hand this beta if you look at the next
character out does not match this
character here okay because if it did
then this Z box should be larger okay so
this character does not match that
character but this character does match
that character which means that this
character well that's all I wanted to
know this character does not match that
character and so again we have Z K Prime
without doing any work okay they're not
doing any actual character comparisons
so the only case that's left is when Z K
prime is actually equal exactly equal to
beta so we know that ZK
is leased beta okay over the length of
beta but we don't and ZK prime was was
also the length of beta
okay but we don't know the full extent
of the match that starts at K and
matches a prefix of of s so what do we
do we do two fingered comparisons from
here and here we know that this beta
matches that beta we don't know beyond
that so we explicitly have to compare
this character to that character if they
mismatch we're done if they match then
we move on match that repair of that
character to that character and so on
everybody got the argument and that's
the algorithm and it's clear that that
is right okay well I mean it's clear
because basically I'm arguing it along
the way that that algorithm is correct
it will compute ZK in the easy cases we
didn't even have to do any comparisons
and in this final case we do explicit
comparisons we know this beta is equal
to that beta and then we're doing
explicit comparisons so you've got to be
you get the right answer okay so that's
the that's the algorithm and the
correctness now what's about this what
about the time analysis this is what I
actually call a bouncing ball kind of
analysis or it's again sort of two
fingered analysis well at the time for
this algorithm is proportional to the
number of iterations which is just
asking we're doing some little things
there comparing the length of ZK prime
to beta and so on that's what all those
subscripts are for but I don't have to
tell you that I mean the that's what the
L and the are for you can actually
compute the appropriate lengths and do
the comparisons that gave you the easy
cases the cases where you didn't have to
do any comparisons actual character
comparisons but if you haven't it if you
have an iteration that actually does
character comparisons
well that error rate that is iteration
is we're on computing Z K the K
iteration if I have an iteration it's
actually doing any character comparisons
that ends up the first time it finds a
mismatch okay and so there
s mismatches that are failed on the
other hand if you're in an iteration
that actually does some matches okay
then you're moving RK RK is greater than
or equal to RK minus one so this is the
the right end remember in all cases when
we're actually doing comparisons we're
actually doing comparisons we're
comparing from our position or R plus
one outward okay and so if that was the
that was the final case where we
actually had to do something do some
actual comparisons so if you're finding
matches then RK is going to be I say
greater they're equal but it should be
greater if you're actually finding a
match
RK minus 1 so the R is moving the
rightmost point of the Z boxes is moving
right well it can't move any farther
than s so every time there's a match if
you're an iteration that does Q matches
then RK is set to R K minus 1 plus Q I
say at least and that's because of the
very firm
K is not in the Z box ok if you're not
in the Z box then you're maybe way out
here this is our but nagging to start
matches again and so the new R is way
out in the front of of the old are well
right if you have if you make Q matches
then RK is set to RK plus R K minus 1
plus Q at least but it can't be any
bigger than s so the total number of
matches during any execution is it most
order s that's the Z algorithm ok so if
I compute all those Z values and this is
linear time because this is most this
isn't most F so that was linear time if
I have all those Z values it turns out
there's lots of things you can do with
them that's what I call it fundamental
pretty
and in particular you can solve the
exact matching problem that I first
introduced what do you do you make s yes
the string that we're gonna compute the
Z values on a P and then some symbol
that's not in the alphabet not in the
normal alphabet so it's not in P R T you
form this string and then you compute
all the Z values of this string okay and
how long is this string by the way it's
the length of P plus the length of T you
find the z values and you note any that
are equal to the length of s oops sorry
length of P okay so if you find and of
course they have to be ones that start
after the dollar sign so you really
would say note any that are equal to the
length of P and that's start after the
dollar sign and that tells you exactly
where in T you found a copy of P so lots
of cute things and nice things you can
do with with this kind of pre
computation or
pre-processing another very simple
problem and this is a typical homework
question if you're given two strings x
and y and y is this is why a circular
shift of x okay so by circular shift and
this is going to come up a lot and when
I talk about burrows-wheeler I just mean
that shift right so the rightmost
character goes in front and then we
shift again the end rightmost character
goes in front again and silver circular
shift so I have two strings is one
circular shift of the other okay well
there were any obvious ways of doing
that but not linear time and here's the
cutest way of doing it in linear time
you just form X X two copies of that
string X and then you determine if Y
occurs in double X well that's the exact
matching problem which we can do in
linear time and and so why does that
work just to give you a little visual
here's one copy of X
next copy of X okay and if Y is in here
well actually it might might even be
that one that you don't have to shift at
all but if you find it here that's
crossing them what does that mean that
means that this was the end of Y it's
already end of X and of X followed by
the start or the prefix of X okay and so
that's a circular shift so why is a
circular shift of X so that's a cute a
cute way of doing that actually that it
turns out there's an even cuter
algorithm for this problem that doesn't
create two copies of X but that's really
just not essential all right so so
there's a huge literature of course on
variants of exact matching and many
elegant combinatorial type algorithms
would call it a combinatorial type
algorithm and so this is only intended
to be a kind of a first taste although
perhaps the most important algorithm in
exact matching and there are many good
books talked a lot about the various
elegant coming Trello algorithms and
when we talk about suffix trees and
suffix array is will get again another
way of doing exact matching and things
that are related to exact matching in
linear time
okay now about 15 or 17 or 18 years ago
I wrote a book which they have upstairs
in the little library section here on
matching type algorithms and in exact
type algorithms in computational biology
and so this actually is is from that is
from that book so it's it's old and
femme and fundamental and when I wrote
that I was told I want name any names
that that's totally useless in biology
there's because everything in biology
has error there's no exact matching
is you know to ideal a problem in for
biological data and what you really want
to do is dynamic programming that allows
errors and that's that is certainly also
true and certainly was true at the very
beginning when statistics and started
the whole field of computational biology
before the computer scientists go to
anyway but it's turned out that with the
sequences getting so large and the
databases getting so large exact
matching used in the heart of various
algorithms really has come back and is
an important primitive and so people
build algorithms around the core of
exact matching and then do things on top
of them because you need that speed and
you need the the nice memory properties
and so on ok but this is again just just
a first taste of exact matching and the
kind of thinking and ideas that go along
and exact matching and the fact that
that this can be done in linear time and
look I just want to back up in case
people haven't been indoctrinated in
this whole thing the linear time is the
time it takes to just read in the
strings you know what's faster than
linear time is just smelling the strings
I mean you know the fact that you can
find all occurrences of P and T and
times that's essentially the same time
as just reading the strings is really
amazing and there are many algorithms
that are like this where there is in the
literature people claiming that it
couldn't possibly be done in linear time
I mean not that they had a proof it just
just seemed obvious ok and in fact a
great deal of algorithmic computer
science is giving those kind of data
points where what seems obvious like it
takes cubic time to multiply to n by n
matrices is wrong you actually can do
things in a more clever way all right so
I just mean this as a
to this there's a great deal more all
right but so getting on to inexact
matching where we allow errors and we're
in the realm of dynamic programming now
what I'm going to show you here is
actually a a talk I gave which was
intended for undergraduates so I have to
go through this much faster so we're
gonna know how similar two sequences are
not again we're no longer looking at
exact matching but we have two sequences
and we want to know in some way how
similar there are well the definition
similarity there's a lot of different
scope for how you want to define that
but it certainly it should reflect
something that has biological meaning
and usually some evolutionary meaning
mutations rearrangements any operations
that cause related sequences to differ
and just trying to keep track over the
years of all the different biological
mutation mechanisms that exist we have
insertions and deletions of single
nucleotides or residues insertions and
deletions of long sequences insertions
and Asian's of really long sequences
those were found there maybe about 10
years ago and reversals transfer you
know there's about a hundred of them and
I mention this because someday I hope to
write a book about this idea that
evolution is as unlikely as a hurricane
blowing through a junkyard and creating
a 747 there's that basic quote that lots
of creationists make and part of that
argument in their argument is that well
all there is the only kind of mutation
that exists is point mutation just
single nucleotide changes and so the
first kind of refutation of that is to
say whether lots of other mechanisms as
well any rate in this
model we're only going to be considering
fairly simple mutational mechanisms so
the simplest definition of similarity is
used to compute how we to show how we
compute a measure of similarity and this
really is the owner is a very crude
reflection of real biology as I was
saying there probably a hundred or more
known mechanisms of different kinds of
mutations but the computational
techniques extends to more complex and
more realistic definitions of similarity
so here the definition given two
sequences s1 s2 an alignment of s1 and
s2 has that obtained it's by inserting
spaces into or before or after the ends
of s1 and s2 so that the resulting two
sequences have the same number of care
who let me give you an example
so here's s1 here's us two there two
sequences that are different lengths but
I'm going to insert spaces inside either
of these two sequences were at the
beginnings or ends of the two sequences
so that they have the same length as a
result and because they have the same
length that defines aligned pairs we can
say that this T is aligned against a
space this a is aligned against that a
and so on
okay so that gives us a well-defined
notion of characters that are aligned ok
in this example they're ten aligned
pairs of characters from s1 own to nine
of those are identical characters Y okay
yeah yes you're permitted to put spaces
wherever it's effective and desirable
and I'll tell you now the objective
function which you know which of those
resulting alignments do we like okay or
best but the definition of alignment is
just that you can put in spaces anywhere
so that the resulting two sequences are
the same length and then and then we can
define therefore what it means for one
character to be opposite a character and
including the alphabet of which includes
spaces what it means to be aligned with
another character now we'll see that
there's no advantage of putting a space
opposite a space okay so we can forbid
that if we wish and part of the
definition all right so as one possible
measure of similarity to sequences we
might want an alignment that maximizes
the number of aligned characters that
are identical okay
that number is taken as a measure of
similarity and the alignment with the
number of identical aligned in alignment
with that number or that maximizes yeah
we maximize the number of identical
characters that are aligned and that's
called optimal so that's one crude
notion of sequence similarity as I was
saying at the beginning it doesn't
really reflect all the biology that we
understand but it's certainly claimed
definition a simple richer model would
reflect evolutionary history that
actually causes the divergence of those
sequences how those sequences and the
differ okay but how can an optimal
alignment be computed efficiently we
have a definition of an optimal
alignment and now we have the question
of how you can actually compute it
efficiently if you just an exhaustive
search what does that mean just putting
in spaces in all possible ways so that
the two resulting sequences are the same
length and once they're the same length
and we can count how many identical
pairs that are aligned pairs but this is
completely impractical if we just did an
exhaustive enumeration enumeration so
this is assuming that you could look at
1 billion alignments per second this is
an old slide of assume now you know
whatever faster computers are it doesn't
matter though really because you look at
this if we're length 30 okay we're like
50 doing the arithmetic it takes 10 to
the 9th ages of the universe to do it
that way ok for length 300 apparently it
takes 10 to the 203rd ages of the
universe okay so that's too long to wait
and don't ask me how long the age of the
universe is but anyway this is not
possible and anyway
30 even 300 is sometimes a very small
number in terms of what we're most
interested in so this is completely out
of the question so I what do we do first
think recursively so recursive thinking
requires we describe the problem we want
to solve in terms of smaller instances
of the same problem and we need the
right notation for that that this is
when I teach this tons of graduates this
is the hardest part of thinking about
thinking recursively because here I
saying oh start with notation the
notation reflects the algorithm that's
coming so you can't really invent the
notation without the algorithm but
that's the way we typically teach it and
so here for a string s we define s of K
character position K every so that and s
1 through K is the prefix of s
consisting of the first K characters
okay and then we define V IJ to be the
maximum number of identical aligned
characters in any alignment of the sub
strings starting the position one going
to position I in sequence s 1 and
starting from position 1 and going to
position J of the sequence s 2 okay well
because I'm saying this this is a nice
notation simple notation as a clear
meaning but how did I know that that's
what I want I can only know that by
knowing what's what the recursive idea
is
that's coming so there's a kind of an
iterative loop here of trying to figure
it out so here I'm schematically just
showing generic alignment but this this
isn't meant to be a space this now this
little - just is meant to be something
either it's a real character from the
sequence or maybe it's a space okay but
this is in alignment and it it puts I at
this position and it happens to put J
and a position to the right of I and
ultimately we want to compute V and M
where N and M are the lengths of the two
sequences okay at least that will tell
us the maximum number of identical
aligned sequences the optimal maximum
number that's that's possible
it won't yet tell us exactly how to
achieve that it won't say exactly where
you're putting in the spaces but it'll
give you the number and the number is
our measure of similarity all right so
to think about V IJ recursively we focus
on the characters I of s 1 and J of s 2
and ask where these characters appear in
the optimal alignment call it a these
two sequences two prefixes one prefix of
s 101 previous of s 2 and there are
three cases maybe there are there
alignments where s 1 of Iife character
of s 1 is aligned with the j DH
character of s 2 they align to each
other in a or there are cases where the
eye tharok term s 1 appears to the left
of the jade character of of s 2 and
that's what we had in this picture here
they're alignments that look like that
and then they're alignments where the I
scare achter appears to the right that's
just the symmetric case here ok
and that's all there are in terms of
alignments every alignment of s1 and s2
falls into one of those three
possibilities so again what does our
objective our objective is to find an
alignment find a
in alignment that maximizes the number
of identical aligned pairs and the
alignments the whole space of all
possible alignments falls into these
three cases all right so let's look at
the easiest one the alignments that do a
line character I for s1 with character J
of s2 well these two characters are
either identical or they're not if they
are identical then V IJ is this value
we're getting the maximum number well
this is the ya the maximum number of
characters that are aligned characters
that are identical in this alignment is
going to be equal to one because here we
get one that's identical plus something
else well what's that something else
well here I usually stop for
undergraduates but everybody here knows
the answers it's what you get when you
align the first I through answer one
through I minus one those characters
with 1 through J minus 1 those
characters and what is the maximum
number of matches identical positions
that are that have identical characters
that's possible in that range in those
two sub strings we don't know what it is
but we have a name for it okay oh yeah I
hope for the overly Parikh the Baroque
question answer good typically an
undergraduates they don't think and
recursively in terms of oh yes there's a
symbol for this there's a name for that
I don't know what it is instead you've
got an answer which starts telling you
how you would figure it out and and then
I stop them and say but wait a but
that's what we're trying to do at a
higher level okay we're trying to come
up with an algorithm to figure those
things out by thinking recursively at
this point only naming what we want not
actually saying all the details of how
we're going to do it okay so if an ant
baroque no fix
the recursion designer that's us we
don't know how much will be added but
that will be determined by the execution
but we know how to name what will be
added okay
it is VI minus 1 J minus 1 so in this
case when the ice character and s1 is
equal to the jth character of s2 and
we're looking at alignment that puts
those two characters opposite each other
they're aligned opposite each other then
the value V IJ is 1 for the match Plus
this is what you can get in the
remaining portions of those two
sequences we don't have a value for that
but we have a name for it and that's in
that case all right let's do the other
case oh well if if these two align to
each other but are not identical then V
IJ is equal to what well it's just since
you don't get anything for a lining I
and J because they're not identical all
you're going to get the best you can do
is whatever you can get from the
remaining portion of the initial portion
this is when these two characters are
not the same okay so when in this case
when s1 eye lines with s2 J then we have
these two phases all right so what
happens when s1 I appears to the left of
s2 j that's that picture we had way back
way back there okay when I ends up
aligning to something which is to the
left of Jay
yeah okay so in that case s2j what does
that character align to it's aligned to
a space in in a remember a is just an
alignment of the first I characters of
s1 and the first J characters of s2 and
if the ithe character of s1 is aligned
to the left of the J character of s2 in
that alignment J can only be aligned to
a space there's some space that was put
in there okay
so in that case the bet and the space
doesn't give you a match obviously so
you're not going to get a reward for
doing that so V IJ is equal to V I using
all the characters you know the
possibility of using all the characters
from 1 through I of s1 but only the J
minus first characters of s2
symmetrically when s1 I appears to the
right of s 2 then s 1 I must appear
opposite a space and in that case we
have this symmetric relation so in
putting these together we have the three
cases and for if you want to consider
the first one broken the two
possibilities so that what we realize
now is the V IJ equals the maximum of
these these values okay that's what can
be achieved and that's the best that can
be achieved because we've enumerated
we've thought about all of the three
types of alignments and we're going to
take the best of those three values for
values but this this is really the same
case where I is aligned opposite J ok in
the base case if I use come characters
and I but nothing in in some characters
in s1 but nothing else to or the
opposite then that's 0 is you're not
getting any matches ok so now we have
correct occurrences to express a V IJ we
thought you recursively in terms of
smaller problem instances and we can
encode that in a recursive program and
when that recursive program would start
with a call to VN m which is what we
most
rod that's that's the value that we
would like and this top-down computation
vnm would call V and M minus one and
called V n minus 1 m and and so on and
that would be very inefficient because
you'll have a redundant recursive calls
what I mean by that it means that the
same sub problem of computing V IJ for
some values of I and J will be will show
up in that recursion over and over and
over again
now you can figure out how many times
and this is actually top down is
exponential time implementation so data
mutually at this if I'm teaching this
undergraduates I asked them to code this
up and then find the biggest values of n
tournament they're their program can
actually compute in an hour
it's pretty small instead we use the
recurrences in a bottom-up manner we
don't make explicit recursive calls to
determine V values but only lookups to
previously computed V values so how many
values are there a distinct V values are
remedy but we have I J I is as big as N
and J is as big as M so we only have n
times M possible calls and then that
again shows why this top down is so
inefficient if it's of exponential size
your but they're only nm distinct
subproblems you must be calling the same
one repeatedly okay so we take care
bottom-up means we start from the
smallest subproblems so this is
obviously the smallest sub-problem and
at that point V one one can be
determined how do I know that I know
that by understanding no I understand
understanding the recursion the
recurrence recurrences here so you look
and see what's required when you want to
compute V IJ you have to have VI minus 1
J minus 1 you have to have the
i J minus one VI minus one J okay so
that you need those three values but
once you have those three values and of
course you have the string you're ready
to figure out you're ready to apply
these recurrences and therefore figure
out what V IJ is oh I must have made an
error
hi I'm in the middle of giving a lecture
oops anyway that don't work nobody ever
calls me that's why don't we turn this
off okay so in order to compute V IJ we
have to have these values available and
so these can be computed in constant
time we look up this value look up this
value look up this value we know what si
is we know what SJ is we apply the
recurrences that's constant time okay
and the first value that we can compute
after the base case is is V 1 1 and
after setting that we could either do a
v12 or V 2 1 etc so and then there are
multiple different ways of actions are
three different well here's here's J
zero zero and M we put these values in a
table these are the base cases they're
all 0 then we get this is the 1 1 and
after that we could either go down this
way filling in a row as you'll see you
have all the values that you need or you
could fill in you can fill in a column
or you can fill in a row or you could go
diagonally this way so diagonally or Zoe
I said undergraduates um make sure you
say diagonally and not diagonally
okay because the bad things happen all
right you need to defend for
undergraduates to keep them awake all
right if any nobody got that then
afterwards okay so finally we in this
way get down to VN M which is what we
wanted to compute and this is what's
called dynamic programming this word
dynamic programming or this phrase
dynamic programming have meaning in the
1940s or 1950s when it was invented
today it's hard to understand the
connection between this phrase and and
the kinds of algorithms so we usually
just call it DP but here and what was
the total time for this well as I said
each time you filled in a character a
cell here you had to look at these three
values that are neighboring it and look
at the two characters that were here to
find out what case you read that's
constant time and you have n times M
cells so constant time per cell means
that this the optimal alignment that
maximizes the number of identical
matches can be computed in time and M
which is polynomial in n M naught
exponential and and very efficient until
nm get into the trillions or right or
whatever so this is dynamic programming
however all I've explained at this point
is how to get the value they and the
major mistake again at the undergraduate
level and I say this because I've taught
that class I don't know how many times
and in particular just last quarter
remember anymore it ended in January in
December the the classic mistaken
undergraduates is thinking that as
you're going along and filling in the
table you can also figure out what the
optimal not just the optimal value is
but what the alignment is that gives you
that optimal value okay and make a
decision on what exactly you're going to
what spaces are going to be putting in
putting in there and in fact you can't
you have to do what's called a backtrack
or trace back which is starting from
this value asking where did I get that
value from it's one of these three
neighboring and three cases and then if
you have that information for each cell
you can trace back along and here a
diagonal move gains you're aligning this
character I to this character J and a
horizontal the vertical moves means
either you're inserting into s1 or and
s2 and that's an easy homework question
to figure out which is which okay
so total of nm time vastly faster than
exhaustive enumeration and vastly faster
than time down use of the top-down use
of their occurrences but we need to
trace back to actually determine them
that's not not for this next lecture not
in this workshop but in the
undergraduate of course that I did I
teach I have three minutes left I guess
and I can take questions or I could tell
you more let me just say one thing
because I've come to really really
appreciate this there's another way of
speeding up the top down so you have you
think recursively and then you think
okay we're going to do top down and then
you realize no you really shouldn't do
that because you get this exponential
explosion and then in what I just told
you you think about bottom-up
computation but there's another way that
in computer science was I don't know
who gave it this name but we want to
find out lynching memoization okay not
memorization but memo like you're
writing a memo ization and that means
you're just doing the top down recursion
implemented in the standard way which
means in the standard way you're keeping
a stack and it means that you're doing a
depth-first exploration of the recursion
tree so if you think of all the
recursive calls those three ways this is
the the tree of recursive calls you
would have if you did the top-down
recursion it's exponential size and so
we said we don't want to do that but if
you implement top-down recursion in the
standard way it's actually going
depth-first along this tree okay so
you're gonna end up down at a leaf here
before you explore any of the other
parts of the of the tree and at the leaf
you have an actual you've solved well in
this case v11
okay you don't quite yet Benny rate the
point is when you do this top-down okay
when you have actually explored the full
subtree when when you have done the
recursion and you're at a point where
you actually know Vij okay you record it
was the value of V IJ and the point is
that everything in the subtree here so
this is the first call this is the first
time there's a call to V IJ and the
things in the subtree here none of them
are V IJ again because I and J are
getting smaller okay so when you finally
pop back here in the recursion you know
V IJ and you've never been asked this
never asks for another execution of V IJ
those are all out somewhere else in this
tree and at the point you actually have
a value you record it and then you
continue doing top-down recursion but
before you make a call you just look up
and see do I already have that value
okay and if you work it out this is just
as efficient as dynamic programming at
least asymptotically you will never make
the same call twice there's a little bit
more overhead because you're going to up
down rather than bottom up so maybe at
worst case that's about twice but why do
I think this is so important is because
there are many recursive problems this
is not one of them this is this what I'm
talking about here problems that you can
understand recursively you have a nice
recursive program top-down understanding
of them but you the structure of the
recurrences and the dependencies is not
clean enough for you to do it a night to
know what the bottom up calls are going
to be but recursion always memoization
will always discover those whatever
structures in there and and then
do have running time which is just as
good as if you had been able to figure
out those sort of a lazy a lazy persons
way of getting to dynamic programming
and it also in practice you can avoid a
lot of the calls you might do with
dynamic programming one of the bad
things about dynamic programming is that
it's best case is equal to its worst
case you're filling in all of the table
whether you need it or not and
memoization you would only fill in the
things that the actual computation
brings you to okay well that's that's it
on and again there's a huge huge
literature on dynamic programming
applications and ways of making the
objective function much more
biologically realistic but this is again
just a introduction any questions
you know yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah it
can be done every actually there's sort
of a formal treatment of dynamic
programming which shows that every
problem it's hard to say this because
there's no clean definition of what a
dynamic programming problem is but
nonetheless you can sort of prove that
every dynamic programming problem is
isomorphic to some shortest path problem
and then you can hit it with our longest
path problem in a dag and then you can
hit it with whatever algorithms you know
and like for shortest path or longest
path and a star is just one of those
types yeah absolutely
dynamic programming was neither dynamic
nor programming yeah right right yeah
yeah it's just something we live with
and and one of the of course it was it
was invented or credit for this was
given by to bellman and one of his
students is Hubert Dreyfus but I guess
not Richard Dreyfuss but Stewart Dreyfus
who is a faculty member here maybe
probably retire at this point but
together they wrote a the basic book on
dynamic programming but the treatment I
just gave you is the computer science
view of dynamic fragmenting the
operations research view from the 1940s
and 50s is somewhat different so we in
computer science we just view this as a
recursive top-down programming with a
trick the trick is either go bottom-up
or use memoization
maybe you want to stay with all of this
basically what went well okay so I mean
as I said there's a massive amount
that's known beyond what I just told you
here our space is nm because we're
building this table n times M well you
can convince your it's easy to see that
actually you could just go one row at a
time
well you can go one more a time so every
value only depends only but every value
only depends on what's in the previous
row or what's - it's left in the same
row so you can reuse rows and reduce the
space down from order nm so just order n
however when you do that you you end up
computing this value that's fine we can
compute the value but then we can't do
the trace back we in order to do the
trace back we seem to need all of of
this table here and when I say seemed as
of mentioning earlier there are many
nice results in algorithmic and the
elegant world that somebody who later
lived to regret it said oh you putt
certainly you can't do that
so in cormen leiserson rivest the first
edition that they in dealing with this
they say oh yes you can reduce the space
down to here but then you can't get you
can't do the trace back because we don't
have the information there but in fact
it was already known ten years prior to
that rush burg yeah Hirschberg building
on some previous things that came out of
a time of the theory of formal english
theory showed how to do the trace back
or how to find what find an optimal
alignment having first done just this
kind of computation in time that only
doubles only doubles the total time okay
so in order n m so you can finally do
order n m in space
order em and this this is a little
complicated to explain how to do that
it's in my book and in many other places
as well probably several of Mike's books
but anyway just let you know that is
possible and that trick is is very
valuable in terms of limiting space and
the other point I make about that is
that there was a literature in
computational biology and the name that
really comes to mind is Gotoh where
people tried tricks to reduce the amount
of space needed in this basic
computation but they were only doing it
by you know a little bit and this
reduces space from nm down to order in
assuming n is less than them oh wait
just completely blows that out of the
water
okay thank you very much